hi I'm Chris Manning here to answer your
questions on artificial
[Music]
intelligence let's see what I've
got what are Foundation models and how
are they useful Foundation models is a
term we coined at Stanford to
characterize the class of huge new
artificial intelligence newal Network
models that have been released recently
and are so influential but the idea was
that the same idea of having models that
were just trained by seeing a ton of
data from the world could be applied not
only to language but also to Vision
genomic sequences robotics other signals
like radar and that by having large
large large neural networks see an
enormous amount of data they can get to
understand a lot about the world and a
lot about human languages if it's human
language data these Foundation models
now give us comp computer models with
much more understanding which are being
widely deployed and Reinventing what we
can do with artificial
intelligence how is AI limited by
Hardware energy
consumption the cost of llms and what
can be done about it good question I
think you can turn around the first part
of it and say that a large part of the
dramatic recent advances in AI have been
powered by great increases in the amount
of available hardware and the amount of
available data and yes that does um use
quite a bit of energy but it's really
having these powerful parallel
processing chips gpus and lots and lots
of digital online data um that have
allowed us to do so much in artificial
intelligence I mean as to what can be
done about it well people are hard at
work on all the different dimensions of
this so absolutely people would like to
design better processors that require
less energy beyond that I mean there's a
lot of work that's been done by the big
um Cloud providers to get renewable
energy sources for their data centers so
you know overall um even though these
systems do use significant amounts of
energy they're really not as bad as
taking your international plane flights
for your vacation as to how we can build
models that use less compute and less
data you know a brain uses extremely
little power right you know we run on
way less than an LED light bulb it
suggests that as well as working out
better computer Technologies at the
hardware level what we should be trying
to work out is better ways of doing
machine learning that can learn more
with less data it seems very clear um
that human baby s can learn
significantly more from a limited amount
of data than our machine learning models
yet can but you know that means there's
still exciting things to do in
artificial intelligence
research let's see how can we improve
explainability of AI models that's a
question that many people have been
interested in there are two sides to
that you know one side is to say that
perhaps it's okay to have ai model r
that aren't explainable providing they
do the right thing you know after all
humans make lots of decisions and a lot
of the time they can't really explain
why they thought one way or the other it
was their hunch or the sixense that it
felt like this thing wasn't genuine um
but you know nevertheless there are lots
of contexts whether it's in legal
context or um medical context where
you'd like to have explanations and so
there's a lot of work and trying to make
models more explainable and I think
there are two fundamental levels at
which that happens at a low level you
want to be able to interrogate a newal
network and decide which features of an
input are causing it to make a certain
decision and there's plenty of work
that's doing that so there are methods
like lime that was pioneered by kis
Western here at Stanford that are
looking at those kinds of explainability
in your networks but I think a lot of
the time once we move to very large
neural networks we'd like a higher level
of explainability that the neural
network can actually just tell us why it
is making a certain decision and I think
that's a capability that we're actually
approaching with large language models
that large language models can often
give a quite good explanation as to what
are the features that lead them to
certain
decisions okay in the future will AI be
so smart it won't need human input
that's a good question and I think the
honest answer is no one knows there is a
conceivable world at some point in the
distant future where an AI system can
just learn everything it needs from the
world around it and it doesn't really
need us to tell it things but I think
there's also a lot of very heated hype
at the moment you can see lots of
predictions that artificial general
intelligence is just around the corner
some people think that by 2030 um
there'll be um computers that are better
than human beings at almost all tasks um
I think a lot of those views are fairly
irrational exuberance where people um
have been getting a little bit too
excited by the very genuine big advances
we made in the last few years they have
if you will drunk a little too much of
their own Kool-Aid so on the one hand
there's no doubt at all there have been
really exciting advances and there are
many ways that computers such as large
language models that have ingested just
huge amounts of text you know billions
of web pages all of Wikipedia just know
a lot more than humans do but there are
other ways in which humans knowledge and
ability to operate in the world is
likely to be better than our AI models
for a number of decades to
come okay I've completed the basics of
machine learning and deep learning what
should I learn next um I don't think
that's a question that has a one-size
fits all answer I mean you know one
answer is that maybe you should apply
some of the knowledge that you have
learned I mean I think it's just a great
next step to find a project that's
something that you're really interested
in could be something at work or it
could just be something that's
completely an interest of yours as a
hobbyist thing working out something for
you know rating wines or something um so
you know spending more time actually
building uh AI application from
beginning to end is still a huge um
further learning exercise after doing
one or two of our classes but there are
lots of other great classes you could do
and I think at that point it depends
more on what you're interested in so for
example you know if you're interested in
human languages um do the my natural
language processing course um on the
other hand if you're more interested in
robotics say and ideas as to how you can
have robots respond to events in the
world then maybe you want to do the
reinforcement learning course if you're
interested in something like
relationships between genes and drugs
and protein
well maybe that's graph new networks as
the next step I think you really need to
think about what would be useful and
interesting to
you okay will conversational assistance
and chat Bots replace search engines
that's a very topical question I think
there isn't a single answer I think
search is actually a a multifaceted
thing and there are different answers
for different kinds of Searchers so
maybe I can choose three es so one case
is that people just have a particular
question in mind so my question is you
know whatever it is when is the primary
going to be held in the elections for
California or who is Beyonce married to
or something like that well you know to
the extent that I've got a question like
that yeah absolutely I think we're
already at the point right now um where
um conversational agents llms are great
for that sort of purpose that they're
faster and better than something else
you could use you can also use them for
all kinds of other question answering
related purposes some that you might not
expect so you know if you're looking for
a hotel recommendation for your next
trip to Oregon you know actually you can
do that very well if you just like to be
suggested at a hotel that a model thinks
would be good for you but there are also
a lot of other ways that people use
search so sometimes people use search
when they want to take a deep dive
themselves right you know they're buying
a new tent and they'd like to read you
know 20 pages of reviews of different
tents by outdoor enthusiasts to make up
their own mind well to the extent that
that's what you want to do no you want
to use a search engine that can give you
a list of pages um that' be good things
to read about reviews of hiking and then
a third case that's actually
surprisingly common is what people in
search just refer to as navigational
queries you you know there are lots of
cases where people are making a search
like Honda Odyssey where they just want
to be taken to the page about the Honda
Odyssey um to read about it so it's not
really searching for information it's
really just wanting to be navigated to a
web page and that's obviously not going
to be um covered by using a large
language model perhaps a better example
of that is when you want to do something
transactional like I um want to um you
know check my bank balance and I just
put Chase Bank into the search engine
because it's just easier than typing the
URL okay what motivates you despite the
hype and occasional negative comments
well I think that one has a really easy
answer which is is that this has been
just such an exciting time in artificial
intelligence I've been involved in
artificial intelligence for about 30
years and all through that time have had
a feeling that yes we've been making
progress there have been scientific
advances there have been new ideas for
how to build systems typical gradual
scientific progress but the reality was
that the for the majority of that time
systems didn't work that well progress
was kind of slow there weren't really
applications that were good enough for
human beings to use for many purposes in
contrast the piece in the last 5 years
has just been astounding that it seems
like you know every month or two there's
some dramatic new advance in systems and
their quality we have amazing language
models that do such a good job of
answering questions there's been rapid
um progress in generative AI for doing
things like creating images we're
starting to see that even generative
video is becoming possible um great work
has been done in understanding the
structure and folding of proteins using
artificial intelligence lots of other
applications and all kinds of places so
there's just been this huge amount of
optimism and excitement from everything
that we can now do and the whole world
has become excited by some of these
things I certainly don't want to deny
that there's hype around artificial
intelligence there's a lot of hype at
the moment of people making very strong
and wild claims of how fantastic things
are or how fantastic they'll be in 3
years time but this isn't an hype
machine this is something where there's
exuberance on top of a field that really
is making dramatic advances so I focus
on those dramatic advances and it's easy
to stay optimistic now there's also
considerable concerns about artificial
intelligence there's concerns about the
systems as to whether they're biased
against um different groups such as
different ethnic groups there's concern
about whether the systems will have bad
effects such as that people will lose
their jobs to AI systems and fur out
some people beat a drum where they're
saying that these AI systems will become
so intelligent and good that they'll be
a danger to humans I think those are
different problems and they're all
important to think about but they have
um different responses so relative to
the question of AIC systems being biased
in various ways that's a really genuine
concern and but it's also an opportunity
for for research so there's considerable
research work now including at Stanford
um by some of my colleagues such as
Tatsu Hashim Mo and how can you design
different kinds of learning algorithms
which suffer less from the tendency of
being biased to work only for the
majority subpopulation of a population
so hope y a lot of those things can be
at least lessened in time with improved
data and improved machine learning the
problem of some people losing jobs is a
serious and a real one I mean that's
happened throughout time going back to
you know a period where nearly everybody
worked the land and gradually there
started to be more automation on in on
farms so I think you know it can be
difficult for individuals when they're
jobs change they have to learn new
things they perhaps even have to train
for a different job but I think that's
been the nature of the advancement of
humanity and society as well and so the
main pressure there is on trying to make
it easy for people to find new roles in
a changing world then there are some
people that do what some people call
critty hype of greatly hyping these
super intelligent science fiction AIS
that somehow are going to develop the
goal of wiping out Humanity I think
that's unrealistic on a couple of levels
firstly I think we're a very very long
way from having the technology for any
such thing you know we still just don't
have very good robotics technology for
people to things to move around the
world and control things the way that um
human beings do so fluently but beyond
that I mean there just absolutely no
reason to think a computer has any
particular reason to wipe out a human
being um that our computer systems just
don't have the same basil evolutionary
strategies of you know competing for
food and a human world so I think
there's a lot of projection and fantasy
there and I don't actually think that
that's something we need to worry about
a great
deal okay what's the next big thing
after large language models um there's
an easy answer to that and then there's
a hard version of that question the easy
answer is to say well the technology of
large language models which is
essentially we could take a um piece of
text blank out some amount of it and
then say given the start of the sentence
what will the next word be try and
predict it learn if you get it wrong and
then just repeat over billions of times
that
strategy of well what sometimes called
unsupervised learning or sometimes
self-supervised learning since you're
sort of making your own learning game
you can repeat that strategy in other
areas so you can take a picture and
blank out bits of it and try to predict
what's in the part that's missing you
can take a gene sequence and blank out a
piece of it and try and predict it so
this is then a very successful strategy
that can be used for all sorts of other
domains of human experience and Science
and that leads to the generalization
that we call Foundation models so we're
going to see a lot of broader use of
foundation models in the soon nearby
years but there's a harder version of
that question which is to say if large
language models aren't everything you
need for artificial intelligence um what
else do you need and how can you
successfully build it most people think
you are going to need some other things
that even though large language models
have been incredibly successful they
don't really seem to build the kind of
world models that human beings have
where they have a sense of um stuff in a
physical world and particular entities
human beings corporations and their
relations that's more abstracted away
from particular sequences of words and
so that suggests we need some kind of
different model of artificial
intelligence that allows us to build
that successfully and I and that's
something that you know people are
absolutely working on and you know
people have been looking at things like
graph new networks but I think it's fair
to say no one really knows the answer of
how to do that successfully and so
that's why we're still doing academic
research how do I increase my
understanding of AI Beyond off-the-shelf
packages I've got the answer to that one
you have to build things um it's a
really good learning experience to
actually work on building things for
yourself I mean many of the most capable
AI practitioners just put effort into
building things for themselves
reimplementing things you know one great
example of that that's the Stanford PhD
grad is Andre Kathy um so Andre has had
a career first working at Tesla and now
he's back at open AI but you know he's
also just just a weekend hacker who
likes to build things so you know just
recently um he's written a sort of a
little implementation of large language
models um mini GPT you know completely
from scratch and the reality is that
just by building things for yourself
from scratch even if they um replicate
something that someone has done or a big
framework from a tech company you just
learn so much and that's always a great
exercise to work through
okay will classical Ai and machine
learning algorithms be usable in the age
of quantum Computing um that's a hard
one I'm really not an expert on Quantum
Computing but honestly at the moment I
see no danger at all of quantum Quantum
Computing capabilities I'm displacing
what we're doing in Ai and machine
learning that at the moment people are
still struggling to build really small
quantum computers so those really small
quantum computers can be used for things
like cryptography and the fear is that
because of their different nature then
they can break the kind of cryptography
that we all depend on at the moment both
to keep you know our banking
transactions and government secret
secure but you can only build small
quantum computers and precisely all the
action at the moment in artificial
intelligence is building huge neural
networks and so our quantum computers
are you know you know a million times
smaller than the kind of new networks
we're building now and they appear to be
very difficult to scale so I think
there's sort of no foreseeable future
where Quantum Computing really changes
or stops what we're doing in artificial
intelligence okay what are some
promising new career paths within
AI so there are lots right we're still
at a stage in which there's just a huge
shortage of machine learning engineers
and a huge shortage of people with a
good understanding of neural networks
natural language processing and Robotics
and related Technologies so that if you
get good skills in these areas there are
all sorts of things that you can do one
caution it's hard to know what will
happen in the coming years but you know
clearly the very biggest tech companies
have had a certain bit of indigestion
over the last year or two that for a
while they were hiring up every machine
learning engineer they could find often
paying them humongous salaries and then
they've decided that oh gee maybe we
have um have been just hiring people
because they're available and we thought
we should try and Corner the market and
so they've really pulled back on in
hiring in AI but also in other areas but
you know the flip side of that is
there's every other kind of industry
whether you're thinking something like
other players in the car industry people
in banking and finance people in
construction people who like to automate
mining or agriculture anywhere you look
there are lots of applications now um
where there are ways that you could use
artificial intelligence to reinvent
different Industries and nearly none of
those have been explored and built and
so I think there's just an endless um
need for and opportunities for people
using machine learning um in my spare
time I also um do some advising of
companies and you sort of sort of see
that in all sorts of places right so
there are little startups using deep
learning for weather prediction they're
using deep learning to predict better
diets for cows so they don't burp so
much and release so much methane into
the atmosphere
um doing robotics having drones flying
around factories um so you can monitor
the levels of different supplies without
human beings need to run around the
factories you know everywhere you can
think of places where we can now have
more Automation and that's going to be
using artificial intelligence
Technologies what are some key
challenges in the field of natural
language processing in some ways that's
come a harder question than it was a few
years ago because large language models
were the first huge success of this new
style of self-supervised learning that
we're doing and sometimes even to me it
almost feels like natural language
processing is solved that a lot of the
things that I used to spend all my time
doing not very successfully such as um
getting information out of text
documents you know Finding facts like
for some company you know how many
pollut how much pollution did they
release what was their profit or loss
who's their CEO right that getting
things like facts out of documents used
to be just extremely difficult to do
well whereas a lot of the time now you
can use large language models and they
just work fantastically well and it
seems like we can do natural language
but you know the reality is that that's
still very partial I mean we have sort
of sort of working machine translation
for um large widely spoken languages but
you know there's still opportunities for
it to get better but you know also there
are a lot of things that they're in
harder in machine translation as soon as
you move away from English
Chinese Hindi German right you're moving
into a lot of smaller languages whether
it's smaller European languages like you
know Danish or Swedish or smaller
languages from other parts of the world
an African language like cutu or smaller
Indian language like morati or something
like that I mean for none of those
languages are there good machine
translation systems and it's harder to
build them because there's much less
data available um when it comes to doing
things of generating text you know if
you just want to generate text that
reads fluently you can do it really well
now but if you're wanting to generate
text or indeed to generate images that
Express a particular point in a
particular way we still have not as much
control as we'd like to have um for
building conversational systems
maintaining an understanding of both the
person you're talking to in their
context we're still not very good at
that content M meance either and then
there are lots of the problems that we
were talking about earlier things like
bias um en larg language models
explainability of large language models
so there are still um tons of different
areas to address in the future I'll just
finish with one interesting New
Direction that um some students are
working on at Stanford which is how do
we build the next level up from large
language models so if you're actually
going to be building full applications
with large language models it normally
just isn't going to be the case that
you've got one large language model and
you're done you're actually going to
build lots of components around your
large language model because maybe
there's going to be one large language
model that generates some ideas for a
story there's going to be another large
language model that generates a script
based on that that'll be interrogated by
a third model which checks to see if
there's gender bias um and if so revises
it so you're actually sort of building a
program out of large language models and
that's an exciting new higher level
domain that we're just beginning to
explore here are a couple of AI
generated
questions considering the rapid progress
in NLP what key factors and actions
should the community prioritize for
responsible and ethical AI language
model deployment and development well
it's really good to know that the AI
systems are also thinking about what's
important for responsible and ethical AI
language model deployment so there are
lots of things to think about there we
certainly want systems that don't
exhibit conventional gender biases or
ethnic stereotypes um the fact of the
matter is that all of the current large
language models do exhibit those
problems It's a combination of two
things in part it's because these models
are just trained on a lot of historical
data from the world and well what they
see is that nearly all politicians in
the United States are white males and so
they developed the stereotype that a
politician is a white male you know one
of the things that human beings are
better at is having in their head how
they think the world should be rather
than just knowing how the world has been
and having statistics based on that but
there are also details of the machine
learning models um where they tend to
emphasize majority cases and forget
about the minority cases so we should be
working out how to build models that do
a better job of that um but we should
also be trying to get data from
different sources so it represents
different groups and we should have the
preferences of different groups involved
in the evaluation of models finding
their weak spots teaching them how to
behave so a couple of people at Stanford
have been involved in this idea of jury
learning um Professor Michael Bernstein
and his students and the idea there is
that there isn't sort of one right
answer to how you should behave in many
contexts that different subgroups of
people have different um Impressions and
so you actually want to represent a jury
of your peers and how different people
feel about things and for some things
you want to be sensitive to minorities
and their interests even if the majority
of people don't find something offensive
or minded and so lots of things to
explore in those areas
okay AI system asks what are some of the
most promising and exciting real world
applications of NLP that you foresee
emerging in the next few
years ah tons um so I think we're going
to see a lot more um NLP systems being
deployed very successfully everywhere so
a lot of websites already have a little
AI assistant um in the bottom corner
where you can chat to the AI assistant
about the company product or things like
that at the moment they sort of work but
they're not really that great or at
least I don't find them that great I
think we're going to see a new
generation of ones powered by large
language models which really work much
more fluently um I think we're going to
see much more use of conversational
assistance I mean some people think it's
a horrible Prospect to imagine people
talking to an AI assistant rather than
rather than another human being and I'm
not W to say that we don't want humans
talking to human beings of course we do
we need much more community and we have
in the current modern world but it turns
out that there are lots of people who
would like to get feedback from somebody
or something that can give humanlike
respons
and don't always have the right human
beings standing by so you're thinking
about um how to word an email to your
boss or you're not quite sure what you
should say to your boyfriend it turns
out that you can get advice drafting
help suggestions of what to say um from
a large language model that are actually
useful these days um but you know once
you move out from there I think kind of
there are all sorts of job functions
which now a large language model can
help you with and I think most of us
just haven't thought enough about um
what the models could do so you know
next time if you've got some writing
assignment you know whether you're
wanting to post a job advertisement or
write you know your monthly status
report I encourage you to try it out
rather than trying to write it all for
yourself from a blank page maybe just
write six bullet points and say hey
large language model can you write um a
monthly status report around these
points and I think you'll be surprised
at how good it comes out um to take one
more example um my colleague at Stanford
who does bioinformatics um anall I mean
unall recently reported that he just
took a vacation to Europe with his kids
and the way he found all the hotels to
stay at in Europe was by asking a large
language model for recommendations and
he was amazed at how good the
recommendations were and when things
went wrong on the plans for the trip
because you know kids they do different
things and they might be tired or not
want to do stuff he asked the large
language model gee what could I do
instead this afternoon and he liked the
answers that got you know I'd hav I'd
honestly never contemplated doing that
you know I went on a vacation this
summer as well and I did the
conventional old way of doing searches
looking at websites um Etc you know I
think there's just a whole world of ways
that we can use these models because our
world is so language based and that
we're all just sort of exploring what
some of the possibilities
[Music]
are